[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
linked this week at the round table of
dim lighting
we're hearing about your near-death
experiences
we're taking advantage of this
line we got this phone call line this
phone call live a hotline man i love it
earpod one i love people's voices all
you gotta do is call in when we put a
prompt on the twitter machine
yeah so and these are literally a
twitter machine near-death experiences
and what i mean by that is
like people almost died and we nearly
died we asked for ones that were funny
or bizarre specifically and we got we
got and maybe maybe there's a serious
one or two in there too
i am embarking on a journey i'm making
an investment i'm learning something new
i am currently being trained to do
something to be certified taekwondo and
nope and
it could lead to a near-death experience
it could lead to a death experience
parachuting but it could also lead to
like an eye opening heart opening
life changing eye opening yeah
future defining experience relationship
defining experience
for me and a significant other in my
life
i'm really building this up yeah so it i
think this is the right episode to let
you know you gonna start playing magic
the gathering
no i'm open to it but that's not it
i
am learning
to scuba dive
i am i am becoming scuba diving
i would just play a dumb yeah
um
ever since and let me i just want to
tell you i've been waiting to tell you
about the process of
training
but the thing you know back when we went
on tour we were in australia we're like
you know what when you're coming back
from australia there's a there's that
place called fiji
fly over it and we went
scuba diving that one day
no we didn't we went snorkeling none of
us are certified
and i had
just a magical experience under the
water like swimming in the in the reef
at in the tidal zone on this island that
this boat took us to
and it was just like
so meditative i thought i was and i
think i talked about it on the podcast
as a highlight of that vacation years
ago
that i was
going to cry in my mask it was can't do
that because she'll die no it was just
so
awesome and then that's when i started
to think man
i'd really like to scuba dive
and then i g i start talking to chase
you know chase is scuba certified well
okay so i'm having some conversations
because when you started talking about
scuba diving you talked about it in a
way that there was a you
there seemed to be a heavy dose of fear
involved and every time you brought it
up it was like you were stepping across
a precipice into like a gauntlet of
sorts but so explain that i
have a fear
of
being underwater that's the problem and
specifically holding my breath like i
mean i i jump in my pool and i go under
water hold my breath i'm swimming around
i'm like
very much aware that there's this
timer going off in my in my body that's
like if you don't
get to the place where you can breathe
air soon you're going to die it's like
it's very it's an immediate feeling for
me and it's a it's an important survival
mechanism but you you know and i always
chalked it up to i was never a pool boy
i was never you were a pool boy you went
to the keith hills pool
growing up did a lot of swimming i did
very little swimming in a pool
environment where you like hold your
breath and you get comfortable holding
your breath
swimmer yeah or like a river swimmer and
you don't you don't spend a lot of time
on you you're more of wading and
treading water no ocean swimming
not a lot i mean ocean it's more like
your body serving and stuff like that
you're on the surface you're not i
didn't do a bunch of like
oh the diving in the ocean that's a fun
part when i would go to freaking the
keith hills pool with for the pool
parties they would do that thing where
everybody would cross the pool across
the pool and be one guy in there trying
to tag you
and you and a bunch of other people
could just dive in swim to the very
bottom of the pool and come up on the
other side and never get tagged and here
i am like flailing around i can swim
but
something about being underwater not a
submarine my mom is afraid of swimming
as a kid she dove into a pool and hit
her head
and then she never swam away well maybe
her dna was altered when that happened
and it got passed to you somehow that
could happen you know dna maybe that's
why
i didn't i didn't experience any trauma
but the fiji snorkeling experience was
so formative for me that i was like i
want to do this
i want to be able to go under that water
and not have to come up
it's a great
idea and i'm and plus i think i'm gonna
have to overcome this fear
and then i tried to talk christie into
it she wasn't going for it
uh but lincoln was up for it i was like
lincoln we're going we're playing in
this
big trip to hawaii i was like dude we're
going to scuba dive in hawaii and he's
like all right yeah i'll do it with you
this is also
maybe the plot of white lotus
did that did that enter into your uh
yeah the the the teenager the teenage
yeah they actually did that
scuba certified man well i i'd made up
my mind before then but then i put you
over there i didn't put any plans in
place and then when i watched white
lotus i was like i'm gonna put these
plants in place see how this teenager's
life was changed like he found his
calling in the ocean
spoiler oh well
it's a nice storyline but i wouldn't
call it a spoiler i mean you're the one
sensitive to spoilers i'm just joking
and
so i said all right i'm gonna do this
started talking to chase about the
process he made a recommendation to
hollywood divers shout out to hal and
the team
that i'm i
linked up with
you you got to take an online course
because lincoln and i were doing it
together it took a number of months for
us to get through it you watch a video
you read some stuff you answer some
questions if you don't get it right you
got to answer all the questions again
but there's like five questions at a
time
and it i mean it was probably
cumulatively over three hours worth of
stuff and then at the end there's like a
70 question test i'm like lincoln
you're dude you're you're used to taking
tests you show up and go to school any
day of the week here yeah all right
another test last test i took it was a
freaking driving test when i moved to
california before that when's the last
test i took like it's test taking is a
skill so i was like man i'm gonna be out
just because
a freaking
i don't even know how to take tests like
i don't know how to retain information
did he beat you on the test
um i let him take the 70 question test a
little bit ahead of me and he's moving
fast i'm like how are you moving so fast
you're going to get these wrong you're
gonna fail
and then he he passed with like a 73
and then it showed him all of his uh
answers and i was like well let me
scroll over here
just let me you know let i don't want to
just i just want to like see
if what i'm thinking is the right answer
well your certification is about to be
stripped from you sir i'm just saying
well i of course i didn't do it i just
thought about it okay all right thanks
for clarifying i didn't go over there
and actually verify that his answers
agree with mine
but i bet you that they did
if i would have checked what'd you get
on the test a 91.
okay well okay
it helps to
it helps
you know what i'm not even saying
yeah it just helps to be knowledgeable i
don't want you to be stripped of your
license
but dude
i mean
they'd spend very very very little time
in this course talking about how amazing
scuba diving is
matter of fact there's there's basically
no part of the curriculum that says
remember how awesome this is so by the
time i got to the end of it all i
learned was that like you can die in a
million different ways you can you can
maim and your body and be in all types
of internal pain
i mean
the one thing that put me at ease is
like all right i have a fear of holding
my breath underwater but one of the
first things you learn in scuba class is
never hold your breath yeah you don't
hold your breath you're breathing the
whole time because not just because you
have air but because
if you the further you go down the more
pressure
gets on your lungs and if you hold your
breath under pressure and then you start
to ascend
your lungs become a closed system when
you're holding your breath and then all
those little
paper bags all those little balloons the
air inside starts to expand your
freaking lungs explode that's not good
your freaking lungs explode so you have
to you have to have a discipline
to be constantly breathing how deep does
that become an issue at
uh
i don't know
they just they don't they don't want you
knowing the exceptions
and maybe i didn't know but i i can't
remember that like
but not pulled up not in pool depth no
not like eight or ten feet okay um
don't ask me questions then i'm like
don't listen to any of my facts that i'm
stating about the one thing i'm a little
bit worried about is there's so many
numbers involved and there's like math
and there's calculations gosh yeah
because all this you got all this
nitrogen in your life
you get this nitrogen that has to off
gas and so depending on how deep you are
you have to do all these calculations
and keep all these records you're going
to need a laminated chart like they
mentioned for uh the gut check episodes
that you take down and dive with either
that or like a dive computer that does
it all for you but if you have to yeah
get that i can rent one of those but if
you have to but it's it's really okay i
can't dive past like 60 feet for more
than an hour i'm just throwing out
numbers here but then if you want to go
i'm gonna be 60 feet under the water how
does that make you feel
well i'll tell you how many feel when i
did the next level of training but yeah
they're talking about like you got all
this nitrogen in your in your body and
it has to off gas
and it will accumulate over time so if
you don't wait 24 hours after a dive you
have to calculate how deep you can go
for how long in any subsequent dives
in like in the same 24-hour period think
of all the people who learned this the
hard way yeah so you don't come up to
and you don't get the bends
um and then is that a tick-tock dance
it's it's it's the name of an album
[Music]
you
then move to the next phase which is uh
you get training in a pool
so
we did this at our pool
it was just me lincoln
and matt and ray
were doing that they were supervising
the two of them were supervising our our
training and so we spent like four and a
half hours in my pool this past weekend
learning how to dive
with the with the breathing apparatus
and the tanks and everything the full
kitten caboodle you like
wetsuit oh yeah wetsuit and everything
wetsuit hood boots gloves everything
that i'm gonna have for the next phase
which is going into the open ocean water
certification which is two days i'm
doing that this coming weekend oh gosh
i think i am nice knowing you so this
past weekend we get in the pool and
they're like first of all it's like
even snorkeling when you put your face
under the water
like everything
in your
being is telling you don't breathe i
mean you're underwater do not breathe
that's why you can throw a baby in the
water yeah it's in its instinct that you
have to overcome that you have to start
breathing underwater
and
it's pretty nerve-wracking i mean if
you've ever snorkeled there's like that
moment of acclamation that's like oh i'm
yes body
you can do this
chill out brain you can do this then you
put on the regulator
like yeah yeah you you have it's an
amazing system that you're putting this
vest on that then it connects to the
tank behind you as well as you having a
regulator that you breathe breathe the
air out of the tank and a backup octopus
regulator that you can share with
somebody in an emergency or use yourself
or share with an octopus they don't need
it um
but then there's also a hose that you
hook to the vest
because you wear this vest and you put
weights in it depending on how much you
weigh you've got to be able to sink
so you weigh yourself down even more
than just the tank and the vest
just ballast
and that's how you get back up you fill
the vest with more air yes you have a
you have this trigger over here i always
wondered about that instead of breathing
the air in it pressurizes is pressurized
and it fills up your vest like a pfd
and you can fill it up
a little bit at a time and it's so
interesting and then you can let it out
when it goes into your vest so you got
the pressurized
you know
mixture whatever is in there and then
when it goes into the vest it creates a
buoyancy that wasn't a force that was
existing when it was pressurized that's
crazy yeah i didn't know about this i
always kind of thought that they like
dropped weights or something i knew they
didn't but like that's i don't know how
do you get back up yeah air the the air
mixture which there's you know the air
we breathe is mostly nitrogen yeah and
so that's why when you're down at depth
i can't you know your the nitrogen
uh content in your body increases do you
have to like dial in what the mix is no
no no it's all predetermined yeah it's
just just a tank you breathe out of it
okay you suck it down so yeah there's
this
the thing that we had to learn was
getting in the pool i mean everything
how do you put on fins without killing
yourself how do you how do you put on
your goggles
you know in a way that they fall back
into the water is that what you did you
walked into the pool we did one of those
like
long step into the pool but we didn't do
the like
back flip off the side of a a dinky into
the you'll do that next time you'll do
that this weekend that's the one thing
that i don't i don't know i'm not well
you're like i don't want to do the
backflip thing but over the course of
the four hours like the first thing to
do is alright you're gonna start
breathing underwater let's go down and
sit on the bottom of the pool
and
and you know they say breathe constantly
you gotta you've gotta like breathe
calmly
in and out you don't and then i get down
in there
and i'm just starting to breathe and
yeah i mean there's a little bit of
you have to like suck the air
out of the tank a little bit it kind of
feels that way like it's a it's a
restricted flow of air it's not just
like breathing air right here right now
there's a little resistance that coax it
out and then your brain is still telling
you
this is this is not a good idea this is
a bad idea this is a life-ending idea to
breathe down here under this water don't
do it
and so
at a certain point very early on for me
that's that sensation started to creep
back in and then he's like come up
telling me thumbs up so i come back up
and he could tell no he's like how you
doing i'm like i'm doing pretty good
he's taking an adjustment he's like you
guys are doing great now we're gonna
fill up your mask halfway with water and
i'm going to teach you how to get all
the water out of your mask without
coming up for air
without coming up to the surface i mean
basically you have to learn everything
that could go wrong or make you
uncomfortable or need adjustment that
you can fix it without giving in to the
urge to try to come up to the surface
because again you're 30 60
feet down you're not
you have to get rid of this
notion of
well i got to go to the surface to take
care of this right no no you got to you
got to take care of it right there
so how's lincoln doing at this point
better than me okay i just wanted to
make sure so
phil he he taught us how to clear the
mask
but we go underwater he points at me and
he like does a mask sign like fill up
your mask of water so i like
you seal the top of the mask well first
of all you let air you let water in the
top of the mask you just kind of like
take it off and then it fills up with
water you can fill it up halfway if you
wanted to kind of ease into it then you
put the mask back on you're like
okay
now you seal the top of the mask against
your forehead and you you look up
towards the surface and you raise the
bottom of the mask out and blow and then
you blow out of your nose
which of course is part of the mask and
then the air from your nose fills up the
top of the mask and down down down
forcing all the water out and then you
can put the mass back on it's a freaking
magic trick
did you know this i didn't know it but
before you explained it i would have
guessed that that's what you did
yeah but you've never done it when
you've snorkeled you've never done it no
because i haven't been yeah i mean yeah
because you can come up to the surface
and clear i mean we also had to learn to
clear your snorkel and
stuff i didn't know
but the first time i did that
like
my mask is filled up with water i'm
opening my eyes in my pool i'm like i
don't like to open my eyes in my pool
and then i'm like oh i forgot to breathe
and then i take a big deep breath
and then like my lungs are filled with
air and i breathe out just a little bit
and then i breathe in again and all of a
sudden i'm like having this
mechanic you panic by telling your story
like you're in the cool it was freaking
scary because i was like
i packed my lungs with air and i just
felt like i kept trying to pack more
air in there
and
i started panicking
and then it's like
i had to come up and then i was i've i
you know
i took a breath at the surface and i was
like all right i gotta i gotta get this
under control i gotta calm down
i'm not and i talked to my instructor
about it and he gave me some tips about
like make sure you breathe out
empty your lungs like you breathe out
all the way before you start breathing
in again
and i just had to start telling myself
as long
it doesn't matter what happens with your
mask or anything like that as long as
you're breathing
you can handle everything else
and you don't need to get worked up here
stay calm
it's it's it's a meditative exercise of
discipline to train your brain and your
instincts to turn off in certain ways
and to stay chill because
you know even if you start breath
sucking down a lot of air it's just
going to limit the amount of time you're
able to enjoy your dive anyway because
you're going to run out of air
or or die from panic
so i got to say i'm a little worried
about you i got used to that and then
he's like now we're going to lose your
regulator you're going to lose the thing
that you're
that is keeping you alive
you're going to lose the the hose
and then he taught us how to find it and
put it back in our mouths and like that
was scary because like now i am holding
my breath he's like don't hold your
breath you have to be breathing out
constantly so i'm breathing out assuming
that i'm going to find the regulator to
put it back in my mouth okay so you're
saying that you can't hold your breath
at any point because even if even if
you're not moving
technically can but it when you're
learning you need to develop a
discipline of constantly breathing just
you don't forget make it a reflex yeah
yeah and like because when you're
panicking and if you have to do an
emergency ascent to the surface
you have to keep your luck your airway
open by breathing out so that your lungs
don't explode
so
we did that and and
like put in the regulator and then it's
like practice losing your regulator and
then using your backup regulator and now
it's like all right now let's practice
the symbol for i'm out of air which is
like sliding your own throat symbol
and so then it's like lincoln and i had
to rescue each other underwater by
sharing our air yeah with the other guy
gross
from the now you keep your regulator in
your mouth but you've got a backup that
you haven't used the one for the
occupant that you put yeah the octopus
you put on the other guy and you link up
and you do the hand signals like you're
okay and then you ascend hold on was
that why power
no okay okay i'm just making sure the
okay symbol
is
thumbs up does not mean okay thumbs up
means go to the surface
and i did not learn any racist seminars
just making sure i don't know this
company that you're dealing with i just
i'm just trying to look i'm just looking
out for everything thank you
it's like
yeah yeah i i made sure that i wasn't
working with a racist scuba company it
is important that's i mean
just as important as not dying and then
we had to
uh practice rescuing someone who's
potentially dead at the bottom
wow who got to do that ray played dead
at the bottom of the pool and then each
of this is ray's favorite part
ray
ray is a she you know think like star
wars
o-r-e-y r-e-y yeah
mythical beast too turns out oh wow
yeah she told me that after i saved her
life a couple of times
first time i saved her life i got a
cramp in my calf and i just let her go
and i and i went in to like fix my
cramp mode and then when i then i had to
retrieve her from the bottom again is
there a symbol for cramp uh no there's
just a technique you grab the end of
your fin and pull it towards your knee
to stretch it out okay
and then i got her up and i was like hey
listen i if you were already dead i'm at
least going to handle my cramp she's
like actually you did the right thing
you're supposed to take care of yourself
before you that's like being on a plane
yeah before you take care of somebody
so it's like all of this like
learn to just stay cool honey bunny
no matter what happens because you're
gonna be underwater
and you ain't you ain't gonna not be
underwater and if you and if you're
panicking and sucking down air it's like
you have to learn
so by the end of five hours he was like
you guys are you guys are fast learners
we're gonna go out to catalina we're
going to spend two days
in the open water you're going to get
your certification and i'm thinking
sharks i'm thinking i don't care about
shark i'm not afraid of sharks okay i'm
just letting you know they'll be out
some people are that i'm not that i'm
just afraid of suffocating all right
so i'm thinking to myself i'm not ready
i'm not ready but i kept the equipment
in between oh so you're contemplating
not going because of like your the first
time i panicked i it
that i told you about i definitely had a
thought of
i can't do this
like
i've we've already booked our our trip
to go out to catalina to get certified
we've already booked our trips in hawaii
like i've really built this up i just
can't can't back out now i can't do it
and then i'm like i can't back out now
it's like this in and of itself is a
test
i can do this i just need to chill out
and that was like in
you know the first
30 minutes like the first time i was
breathing underwater so it got better i
can only imagine how harrowing your
story is going to be when you
leave the pool
i know man
yeah i don't think you you would not
have any trouble with this and i asked
lincoln last night i was like dude were
you panicking at any point
he was like that one time you messed
filled up with water you did shoot to
the surface he was like yeah but after
that i was totally cool i was like
you're too young to think about dying
the main the main issue i would have is
the issue that i have while snorkeling
is my beard and people say oh you put
the silicone
stuff or whatever but like i i've tried
it and my mask leaks and you know me i'm
not losing the beard no just all you'd
have to do is shave your mustache yeah
you know me
amish rhett you would have to be amish
if i make a commitment to the amish
lifestyle i'll become a scuba diver but
that might be a conflict i don't know if
they believe in that technology last
night
i said lincoln let's get back in the
pool and practice one more time there's
some air left in our tanks
and we got in
i spent probably an hour and a half in
the pool last night
take it like losing my regulator holding
my breath underwater and like well
breathing out while i try to recover my
my air supply
and just laying at the bottom of the
pool and just trying to
put myself in that mental space of
if you get worked up
just
breathe calm your breathing
so i feel more comfortable
after doing that
and i also know now what it feels like
to
for to run out of air because
i i practiced until literally that the
tank was empty
which that's a scary feeling
so i go up to lincoln and i'm like mine
ran out before his and i'm like doing
the symbol and like he's like
we actually did it it's like i took his
and we but like
it's a scary feeling when you're you're
sucking your air and it's like it's
getting more difficult and then all of a
sudden it's like
how uh
is there any sort of warning
no you just have a gauge well there's a
gauge there's a gauge that you're
constantly monitoring
but i've forgotten totally about why i
got into this so i'm trying to get back
into that space and i hope when i go to
catalina that like it's gonna be
a beautiful experience that's going to
be like yes this is why i was doing this
because all i've been thinking about is
worst case scenarios well it's not going
to be fiji just so you understand that
like i mean he said he said there could
be i've seen like beautiful videos from
people who have
dove around catalina but it's not fiji
you were like in an aquarium
yeah like a be like it's not gonna be
that great
so
and i've just kind of talked about like
all of the stuff that's made me really
scared but i'm but i'm balancing that
with
the experiences i'm gonna have
with my
son
and with nature
so he's not nervous not nervous no
so he's a good buddy
i was like lincoln if i'm if i start
doing this like
zen
breathing breathe out symbol with my
hands it means that i'm panicking don't
try to get me to do anything else just
come over and just like smile part of
the training
no that's something i developed okay
maybe maybe they'll add it to the
curriculum
man
so
we'll get to your near-death experiences
but i've got to talk about
dispatches from real beach i don't have
we talked about dispatches from myrtle
beach on this show not on this show
we talked about it on gm yeah we've
announced it um
and i just i mean i just listened to the
uh the trailer which is out um
for this podcast which is
charles neal and link neal that's link's
dad
uh
and let me just tell you i mean i'm very
excited i know that you've already
recorded an episode yeah um
but
i mean we when well it comes out this
thursday when you just i mean you're
dead last thursday your dad's watching
the video your dad's voice is iconic
and now we are we're monetizing it
he has been so excited once i started
talking about doing a podcast and i'm
like
dad this is
your podcast and i'm just like your
sidekick i'm here to
i'm just here to talk to you and catch
up every week every thursday we're going
to publish our conversation where we
catch up but there's going to be we have
different segments planned different
things that he's going to talk about
um so yeah he's driving the ship
and i i'm i'm an interesting passenger
on this journey of
what is this
what is this gonna is this gonna become
something
and i think it really comes down to is
it is it gonna become something in my
dad's mind and in his life like if is
this gonna legitimately be an outlet for
him like so far he's got hundreds and
hundreds of emails
from people ever since way back when i i
tweeted his email address people didn't
believe me and then he's like elated to
be getting
so i got 300 emails he's about to get in
one night he's about to get more yeah
rather be shagging 53 aol.com
this is email address
so yeah every thursday wherever you get
your podcast dispatches from myrtle
beach my dad has a podcast where he
talks to me
so go over there and uh subscribe and
follow whatever you can do even though
an episode's not out if you're listening
to this but if you're watching the video
the episode's up the first episode's up
you can go and actually listen to it
right now wherever you get your podcast
the things that we talked about in the
first episode uh
i ended up giving him quite an education
of course he i learned some things about
him too i don't want to give anything
away
i just want you to go over this i'm
excited about this
i haven't listened to i'm going to
listen to it as a
uh
as a consumer
you know what i'm saying we're trying to
keep the episodes at like 30 minutes so
it's like it kind of feels a different
niche in your like listening routine
than say your biscuits
so yeah
thursdays dispatches from myrtle beach
let's start with uh hearing a near-death
experience so this is actually a very
american story i almost choked to death
on a corner of a hot sauce packet while
eating lunch at work
i uh
had ripped it off and i guess i didn't
throw it away properly
and it somehow made its way into my
sandwich and when i tried to swallow
it got stuck in my esophagus or whatever
it is that blocks you know stuff that
isn't supposed to be going into your
stomach well you oh no it blocked your
wimp i was all alone i had my own office
and no one was around
i had a walkie-talkie but couldn't use
it because i couldn't speak because i
was joking
and
i
had no clue what to do i ended up trying
to dig it out of my throat it didn't
quite work
and
i
uh ended up just trying to make myself
throw up
and uh that did work so i did not die
and i lived to tell the tale but that's
the story of me being american and
almost choking to death on something
that could have been prevented if i had
just not been so hasty while i was
eating thanks for sharing your story but
there's a couple of i just can't believe
this happened i mean the
typically the corner of a hot sauce
packet is not a chockable
it depends on it depends on how good of
a rip you get and how deep it goes i
think and if it just went into the
windpipe well she said esophagus but
drake tracheal trachea esophagus right
they said
they meet
it must have been at a spot where
because because making yourself throw up
is going to bypass your windpipe if it's
gone deep enough well it's probably
right there at the intersection of the
two
uh and and i don't know i'm not no
doctor but i think that
if something is like lodged right there
at the top of the trachea
it's more than anything
it's super it's super unpleasant but if
you were to
stop and not not cough
you would find that you're still able to
especially in this case get oxygen
into your lungs
now
i'm not a doctor either but my
understanding is you're taking that
scuba tube you do not give someone the
heimlich maneuver if they're making
noise because that means that there is
some sort of air flow well if they're
like
they're beating a table that's noise
just to clarify if there's no noise
right
it's like you must be silent calm down
and don't say a word or make a sound
before i do the heimlich if they're
coughing and making noises there's still
air coming from their lungs in some
capacity right then there's not a
complete blockage and it won't work
it'll just break their ribs or whatever
again not a doctor
this is not medical advice
in the event of choking go to google and
figure out what you're supposed to do
or do that right now and then be ready
for when it happens the american part of
it like
hot sauce packet so americans are
associated with hot sauce packets i mean
i'm sure they've they've ventured out
beyond america but you know i think that
it was like this super convenient little
pack of something and this disposable
thing you know it's it feels it feels
very american it's interesting that it
was in the sandwich and that's the
foreign object in the sandwich is what
made her choke but any part of the
sandwich could have made her choke
but she knew it was the hot sauce
i guess so the hot sauce packets i mean
it's going to grab on in a way that food
is not going to grab on yeah yeah
i'm not a doctor this is disturbing
let's go to another one i rent link my
name is jacqueline and my near-death
experience
was when my boyfriend at the time who is
now my husband left me alone at his
apartment complex while i was there i
heard a really loud chainsaw noise and
it was so loud i heard girls outside my
apartment screaming bloody murder and i
thought there was a chainsaw man on the
loose i even filmed it i have a video of
myself wondering where the chainsaw was
coming from and i in the moment did not
think to call the police or do anything
rational but i ran out of the apartment
without my shoes on down three flights
of stairs jumped into my car and drove
and parked in the nearest piggly wiggly
parking lot
when i got back after sobbing thinking i
almost died from a chainsaw attack i
found out it was a man doing donuts on
his motorcycle in the parking lot and i
literally thought i was going to get
chainsaw to death so
that was my near-death experience man
doing doughnuts yeah i think she was a
chainsaw man man doing donuts
i think the piggly wiggly parking lot is
maybe not the safest place on the planet
i mean i no i i just i mean i think
there's i i listen not a sponsor i hope
maybe pigley wiggly will sponsor us at
some point but just
based on my piggly wiggly parking lot
experiences
you know what being at home is probably
safer
yeah
i've watched the piggly wiggly burn to
the ground before
that one in lillington you were present
for that yeah
i just walked over
to the edge of the nano and papaya's
neighborhood and sat on a berm and just
watched it burn
you're joking
don't you remember when that happened i
remember hearing about it but i didn't
see it i remember driving by afterwards
you know typically when somebody like
arsonist this type of thing they do yeah
look at that little teenager sitting on
a berm watching a piggly wiggly burn
suspect number one the chief of police
grandson
yeah it all adds up
hold on did you burn it down i didn't
for the record i did not burn the pigley
wiggly down who do you think somebody
did was it was it arson uh no it wasn't
arson as far as i recall we had a lot of
arson in our parts
hearing a chainsaw and immediately
thinking of a chainsaw man is uh
you know that that's kind of relieves
the screams though the screams yeah
that's scary and and now that
now that we do understand what was
happening and it was a doughnut man not
a chainsaw man doing doughnuts where the
scream screams of glee
yeah because that's a good way to get a
harnett county woman excited i don't
know what it is
more excited more quickly can you do a
donut
yeah
now it does remind me of
um
lincoln's gotten into manga
he was reading i was like let me let me
look at this one that you're reading he
was like
okay
it's called chainsaw man whoa
and it's this and i just started
flipping through the book and he's like
first of all you're flipping backwards
it's
it's you know start from the button you
got to start from the back dad and i was
like well
spoiler alert
it's the most disturbingly well
illustrated disturbing scenes i've ever
seen like
like the the the creatures
there's this creature called
santa claus that has nothing to do with
santa claus that then like is an
amalgamation of all of these
things that it like
uh starts to control
like baby doll heads that turn into that
like they group into like the legs of a
spider creature that is like one of
those what do we call
the things where you just have a
eyeballs and hair
oh
you love this type of stuff you would
really be into it but the chainsaw may
have one of those is a guy that i don't
know what triggers it uh it's a very
famous
manga written and illustrated by tatsuki
fujimoto so this is it's in japanese so
he's just looking at the pictures how is
it translated i think it's translated i
was just looking at the pictures there's
it's mostly pictures so when they
translate it they don't also flip it but
the chainsaw no the chainsaw man
it's like when he turns into chainsaw
man
a chainsaw comes out of his head and out
of his hands and it destroys his body as
he's transforming and it's very
grotesque quite a sacrifice it's very
grotesque and there's a um
there's a there's there's a video series
that's coming out well i hope so he's
very excited about it i was like i don't
know if i can watch that with you it's
what is it like to have
to be
a child and have a dad
who is the one that gets scared
of scuba diving and manga
it's scary what is that going to do for
him it's legitimately disturbing i was
like son doesn't this disturb you i
think he's in the wrong i was like
if this doesn't disturb you
no it's cool man
it's cool it's troubling to me
it's troubling to me
but i'll watch it with him
i'll give it a shot
hey guys my name's amber and about four
years ago during a nice thunderstorm and
went outside to record the water coming
down the road there's a light there's
like there's a lightning strike really
close and i don't remember much but i
ran inside and watched the video back to
see that it was like right next to me
and slowing it down frame by frame is
even scarier and i haven't been out
during thunderstorm since
i still have the video if you all want
to see it too and i don't really know if
it's considered near death but
uh it was definitely scary so yeah
thanks bye-bye well we're watching the
video and i can tell you right now yeah
this is near death turn the sound on to
amber's video at mingypoo
emin
j-i-e-poo with two o's okay
all this water guys
it's awesome we could freaking tube
guys
it's awesome we could freaking tube
wow
all this water
water i like the way she said that
obviously she's just funny but amber
amber was so excited about the ability
to tube down that
creek
ditch
wow good lord i mean so see if you can
it lights up like half the screen go go
back to there and kind of do the frame
by frame thing she was talking about
i don't know if you can do that with
twitter but basically oh like whoa
i mean it phases out the
the camera on the
but look it's like lighting up the whole
it's pink
it's very pink wow
that's crazy
that is crazy
and she she screamed
at the same time it hit
[Laughter]
all this warrior
amber we like how you say water
[Laughter]
and then she said uh i left a voicemail
and i think i talked too fast no i l we
like it when you talk fast that's good
keep it short keep it sweet
yeah man because i glad you're okay i
think that i miss
thunderstorms i seem to remember like
the
baddest scariest thunderstorms happen
when we were at church
on like a wednesday night there'd be
like there'd be pink lightning
and you got that pink lightning only at
church i just have those memories
yeah they happen quite a bit
i written link my name is jacob and i'm
from charlotte north carolina and my
near-death experience happened on the
second week of my freshman year at
college at western carolina university
up in kelowe near asheville a group of
friends and i went up to waterfall one
saturday and i was not being
particularly wise as i was walking on
some rocks on top of a waterfall
so of course i slipped and i fell on my
stomach down
one small waterfall and then another
until i fortunately landed in a pool
deep enough to stop me about a small
car's width from a 50-foot drop to just
a pile of rocks
to make matters worse the pool i landed
in was full of leeches and they were all
over my legs all the way up my swimsuit
and one last thing i was with a group of
friends from a campus ministry i was in
at the time i have a similar
deconstruction story to y'alls oh and
the guy that helped pick the leeches off
my legs kept complaining about how weird
it was and how uncomfortable it made him
so that was a great saturday
yeah that that
they getting a little homoerotic there
a little uncomfortable for the is that
is that what was happening i think it
was it was just like oh no i just kind
of think pulling leeches off somebody is
weird i know it's spirituality aside
like belief system aside i think my
understanding was why he made the
connection is if a guy was a little
uncomfortable with getting close to his
junk or something dude freaking going
off of a water you got to be freaking
careful man if you're like hanging out
around a waterfall and if you're in the
water that then starts to
eventually falls
it's just not a good practice you don't
want to be in pre-water fall water
you know
yeah and it just seems like a uh
something to live by well the most i
don't swim in pre-waterfall water the
most uh visceral this has has ever been
for me
was when we went we visited niagara
falls
and so there's been plenty of times in
my life when i've been like in a creek
or in a river that had a waterfall and
you're like kind of swimming and you're
like i'm not gonna go there because it's
a waterfall yeah there was one time we
were we were swimming in yosemite when i
was a kid like i mean i remember this
very clearly because my dad was like
there's a waterfall down there and then
years later we heard about people who
would be swimming in yosemite and get
swept down and go off a giant waterfall
and die yeah the year that i was there
we hiked to the top of yosemite falls
and they they were doing a helicopter
rescue of someone who had gone over the
falls yeah
but when we went to niagara falls when
we visited niagara falls with our wives
yeah uh and we we were on the
we were on the canadian side right which
is the better side
not nothing against america but just
it's a it's a it's a cooler side
picturesque of of the uh the river
it's crazy like you can get right down
there next to i mean you can't really if
i remember correctly you can't like walk
to it or whatever if you're just a you
know a civilian
but
obviously you don't want to go off
niagara falls and
just the other day i saw a video going
around i think on twitter and it was the
guy who cuts the grass
what at above the falls
and he's got a rope tied to him
so like the person who's like he's
blowing the grass is he on a riding
lawnmower with a ride
he had a push mower because it was like
kind of like
uh it was a place you didn't want to be
like
on a vehicle that could fall in it was
just like okay i'm kind of mowing the
grass here wow and i'm and i'm and i'm
buckled in
here we go there you go
there he is right there
dude using a push mower and he's got
like this giant yeah that makes sense
harness around him
ain't a sleeveless shirt well you don't
think he weighed that i think he's just
wearing
that's a mo job i don't want you know
really
extra challenging though
that's beautiful though that's advanced
mowing people go yeah there was the
person who drove their car
and was like the car
with the person in it was like
close to the edge of niagara falls like
a few months ago
and they had to do a rescue to get the
person out of the car they were in the
water yeah
yeah
and yeah i guess if your car i don't
know if they were i don't know
don't get out of your car because then
you're you're in serious trouble good
gracious i mean you yeah but imagine
going over a waterfall landing in a pool
and then struggling but then jacob went
over again landing in a second pool and
then he finally got it together because
if he'd had gone over that third one
he'd he would have been
he'd have been in a thousand pieces man
and then yeah pool full of leeches and
an uncomfortable moment with a friend
man
my bizarre near-death experience
happened when i
had to get foot surgery on my big toe
they thought it was a
bone infection or something like that
so went in for the surgery at an
outpatient center
proceeded to apparently go into
anaphylactic shock on the table
allergic to some of the medications they
gave me for the surgery
i woke up was told about it um and i was
the outpatients center's first code blue
ever
so that is my bizarre near-death
experience that my
big toe tried to kill me dang i mean
that's scary because this is a group of
doctors who are not accustomed
necessarily to dealing with outpatient
yeah you know code blue
yeah it's like we're just going to take
care of your toe i mean just makes me
think every time they ask me
are you allergic to anything it's just
like i always brush it off of course not
pollen when i was little my mom would
say he's alerted to amoxicillin because
as a as a as a baby he had a
little reaction to it but then at a
certain point i just stopped saying that
well when was the last time you had
antibiotics i don't know
many years
because i mean there's still a big class
of antibiotics i mean it might be worth
finding out but
you usually what will happen is you're
not going to die like
you'll be in like the first or second
day of taking them usually and then
you'll be like this happens to jesse
should be like oh i'm reacting to this
and then you just stop and get on
another one
um that's i had toe surgery it's only so
that's only surgery i've ever had
when you broke your toe after the the
basketball tank no ingrown toenail
oh you got that
uh i had an ingrown toenail uh in high
school
and went to the podiatrist
and still the one of the i got some
messed up toenails in general but one of
them on my
big toe
like you can kind of tell that what they
what they do is so that
there's one one side of one of my big
toes oh no it doesn't go under the skin
the nail doesn't like go
it doesn't like meet the skin i mean
listen you got to learn how to scuba
dive and you got to take this kind of
stuff man
and so they did something where they
like cut it so that it would
and i was fully awake and it was just
like numbed or whatever
no code blues for me
but yeah that's the one surgery i've had
is toe surgery big toe surgery that's
what we've got in common it's so
interesting to wake up from an
outpatient surgery and they say
oh you died for a second it's like what
like my toe died for a second no you
died for a second
is this well this is kind of crazy
because for two reasons two things that
i've that i've been uh looking into
lately the first is i just happened to
see like a
article yesterday
and it was like a collection of people
who woke up during surgery in their
stories
see i i wonder i wonder if we're going
to get the numbers back on this episode
and be like nobody clicked on no one's
listening to this episode because
they're smarter than i am no i didn't
realize that i didn't want to hear this
well here's the thing you don't like
chainsaw man but there's a market for it
okay i'm the market for it and i'm
speaking right now why do you why are
you reading about people waking up
during surgery because i have a fear of
that happening but but then why read
about it to know how bad it's going to
be to be prepared like to yeah see
you're convinced it's going to happen it
wasn't as bad as i it was i mean there
was a couple people who were like it was
the worst pain i've ever experienced
nothing has ever come close but there
was a couple people who were like i woke
up everybody saw me they
gave me a little bit more of the juice
and i went back to sleep
i won't go in any more details about
that but the second thing i've been
reading about so you're telling me it
made you feel better reading about those
things i felt the same
uh
the second thing i've been reading about
and i and i'm interested uh i find it
interesting that we didn't get any of
these
and and daniel is it that we didn't get
any
at all or that they're not in the in
these ones that we're selecting from in
terms of people who actually like saw
something like saw the light all the
light
okay no one in the mythical beast
community has seen the light um
and i i wouldn't say that i am um
like go i haven't gone hardcore like
deep into this but i'm just i'm finding
myself
um
reading about and like watching like
documentaries about people's near-death
experiences
and actually experiencing like
out-of-body stuff i mean i still don't
know what i think about it i'm in an i'm
in an open place
uh is it like okay this is just
something where there's like dmt
released in your brain when you die
and you feel like this is what's
happening yeah um but it's pretty
fascinating how i was i was actually
hoping we would get some of those
submissions based on some of the stuff
i've been reading because they are
relatively common
and
there's all these
scientists you know people who had like
a completely materialistic naturalistic
view of the world where they're like
consciousness is completely contained in
the mind who basically began looking
into this
and were like i can't
in good conscience continue to believe
that that's the case that something else
must be going on with all these things
that are happening to people and of
course this is not anything new people
have been talking about this forever but
um
i don't know i was a little intriguing
my granddad um
my mom's dad you know he passed away in
1996.
i remember this so in 19
i mean he had two separate open heart
surgery
procedures
like where they you know they split you
open at least back then from from
sternum down like down your thigh
like the the scar that he had is just
like crazy training oh so deep i don't
know
it's like trying to open a book and you
really just gotta
you gotta keep ripping it yeah you keep
rip like you gotta stretch the the
spinal
nasty i don't i actually don't know if
it was related to one of the second one
of those or
something else but i definitely remember
sitting at the kitchen table after while
he was recovering
and he said
that
he when he was under
and he
i don't remember if they said that he
coded for
any period of time like i this is not
the type of story that you want to go
back to and like talk to relatives about
uh when you're just shooting the breeze
but he described going to a place that
was like a ultra dark
warehouse like a real creepy huge
dark warehouse
so like the opposite of going to the
light and i'm and he's telling me this
story
and i'm thinking
man my papa went to hell he went to the
hell warehouse he went to is he is that
like the
he went to like an abandoned sam's club
he said he was scared he he said it
scared the shot at him
you start living right
he started living right yeah
i don't know he his jokes were
always very colorful he kept saying fart
blossom
yeah but i remember being concerned
about his soul after he told me that but
he wasn't that that wasn't the
implication when he was telling it it
was just kind of a matter of fact like
this this happened well i was like what
do you do with this information
and it isn't it seems like not much well
based on what i'm seeing
there are things that are that people
have in common but but also it's not
like
everyone who is a professed christian
sees a light and everyone who's not sees
a dark warehouse or feels a little bit
of heat it's like it isn't like oh no
this is supportive of a christian
worldview but it is um
it's supportive of the fact that
something happens when you get near the
point of death
and i and i question
if
consciousness is completely contained
physically in the mind in the brain and
that there is no mind beyond that or any
consciousness beyond that like what is
the evolutionary advantage
of this release
in this thing that happens at death like
i mean of course if you're if you're
essentially a computer
and the computer is shutting down some
weird [ __ ] could happen in your mind
that then if you come back from the if
you actually reboot some weird might be
still in there but maybe it's just a
gift you know it's like the gift of
existence is that when you're when
you're transitioning as some people call
it or dying as other people are calling
it uh giving up the ghost or however you
want to say it that there's like a
there's a there's a little bit of a
release of something that gives you a
positive experience
ushers you out but this is the thing
that this is the thing that's so
interesting
and we could do a whole episode on this
maybe we will maybe we'll do a
flatliners episode where we do it to
ourselves maybe so you don't fight it as
much you know but see here's what i'm
saying so i don't want you to dismiss it
if you're listening the thing that
is they're not they're no longer
conscious their brain stops functioning
this one woman
was dead for 30 minutes
okay drowned
and got like a kayaking accident okay
not scuba pinned under water under a wat
she went over a waterfall in a kayak
because somebody was in the way
this is like episode one of one of those
netflix series
she goes under the water she's under the
water they they basically after 15
minutes it turns into a recovery
operation not a rescue operation because
she's been in underwater for 15 minutes
they eventually see her life jacket and
a guy like is going to get it to be like
i think her husband would want this and
she's attached to it whoops pull her out
she's blue her eyes are fixed open she's
dead
i don't remember exactly how they got
her to they they i think uh they like
put her on top of a kayak she was in
chile i think and she
not a big bowl of chili the country
chile and she she they go up the uh path
and there's an ambulance there like some
serendipitous stuff happens
anyway she has all this stuff that
happens where she saw she basically saw
all this stuff happen that she was like
out of her body watching it happen she
was a very she was a person of science
she was a doctor she didn't believe any
of this stuff she didn't have any sort
of supernatural paranormal disposition
or enough kayak training but she spent
time with people
who were very welcoming and like it felt
awesome and warm and everything and they
told her you have to go back but they
also told her basically that her son
was going to die
what
and so she had this feeling or had been
communicated to her that her son was
gonna die
uh and that he wouldn't make it past his
18th birthday
and he it was like on his 18th birthday
he was in like a skiing competition and
she like goes to him the night before
and she's like i've never told you this
because i didn't want to freak you out
but i don't believe you're gonna i think
you're gonna die
and uh he lives through the skiing
competition but
then what two years later he dies oh
so they were off by two years i don't
know if they told her specifically that
it wouldn't be until 18 but that's what
anyway so she like her whole world view
has changed and she's just one of like
thousands of people who've had weird
like this happen to him
um again i don't know i don't know i
i hate this episode why are we doing
this but it's so interesting that you
don't like it
all right so i got a near-death
experience that's uh
pretty comical
and uh good terrifying at the same time
so me and my friends we were hiking up
raving cliff falls
down here in georgia
you guys from north carolina might have
heard of it before nope heard it george
you're hiking up the waterfall and we've
made it up the waterfall we already
stopped so we're on the hike down
and
i slip
i slip way up high
on this little mountainside
and
i don't know how
somebody up there might have been
looking out for me not sure
but i was able to
grab a hold of a tree
and kind of
maneuver my way back up
and
you know i get two people come rushing
out at me and they're like
are you okay like what's going on my
friends laughing panicking
i'm like yeah i'm fine i don't i don't
realize how bad it was until later
i'm brushing myself off i i continue
walking and we get down
the cliff and my friend that was with me
she uh
she points up at the tree and goes
that's what saved your life
i look up at that tree it's about a 200
300 foot fall
from where that tree is so
that tree wasn't there
i
probably would
not be leaving this voicemail right now
but uh yeah so
i became a tree hugger that day i don't
regret it
love your show
keep on keeping on
and being your mythical best
hey that was good delivery man and
especially the tree hugger part that's
tough man
if you're going to have a ned death
experience it's better to not realize
until after the fact
yeah that's the way i want to do it
well it might happen to you man you're
stepping in you're stepping into the
gates of hell
no it's just the ocean
poseidon
and i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna ease into it
you know it's two days of being guided
into like
more comfort
it's gonna be fine link
um
that reminds me
another thing that happened on that show
is that there's a series of what's the
name of the show
so you don't even know what it's called
surviving death okay that's the name of
it but the other thing that they talked
about i'm only like two episodes in it's
not even new it's been out for a while
um
people
falling
great distances
and having these like blissful
experiences
uh while falling it's kind of hard to
understand exactly i think it's they
fell great distances and nearly died
like there was an impact at some point
and
but they look at that experience as like
the best moment of their life because of
what they experienced in some sort of
like
transition so i mean that can't happen
to you in the water necessarily but
i'm sure something cool could happen to
you
you could have a moment that you you
could do a whole episode on
i written link in my fellow podcasters
my name is maddie and living in the
beach south was absolutely nothing to do
i've almost died a few times but the
funniest was definitely when
my brother was given a go-kart for his
eighth birthday and little
three-year-old me
um he decided that we were gonna go on a
little
trip um on the field
and um
to his benefit of the doubt he told me
to hold on and i did not
and he took a very sharp left turn and
according to my dad and him
he turned left and i did not i
was ejected from the cart and i just
started barrel rolling down the field of
little three-year-old and apparently my
dad was sprinting towards me um and
because i was just laying there lifeless
oh that's what they thought but i'm fine
so yeah thanks guys
go cart you you bought a go-kart for
your children
yeah um
let's see it was i mean it was six years
ago i don't have it anymore i sold it
because like lincoln was afraid to uh
drive it it was like it was a two-seater
go-kart that like
my neighbor sold me because his kids had
gotten older and it had like a roll cage
on it and they wore helmets and
but like
lincoln had had a bad experience riding
the golf cart at my nanny's house and
like he was riding it with uh louis and
louis fell asleep
in the golf gator in in the golf cart
and then
what and then lincoln hit the bath the
cement bird bath and then ran over
lincoln was driving and his driving
instructor fell asleep yeah yeah
so he was scared to drive
the go-kart that i bought kill any birds
nope no birds were bathing at the time
that
that bird that bird bath stayed teetered
over for for quite a while
um
yeah and then
lando was not was not his legs weren't
long enough to drive it
so i got rid of it but when i was a kid
jimmy got me and emmy a go-kart had no
roll cage
no helmets you know two-seater and we
would zoom around the house and
um
she she would be driving and
she would turn so sharply that the whole
thing rolled it like it didn't roll all
the way over it like teetered all the
way up and like
dumped us out and then kind of landed on
top of us
and it was like you get out from
underneath and you're like it's kind of
like when you fall you're like did
anybody see me fall we're still good
we're still good turn that thing back
over
did you have do you remember ever riding
that guy i don't think i drove that guy
at my house go cart because my cousins
had three wheelers
i mean those are damn like the first
atvs were three-wheelers yeah and they
had a little one and they had a big one
and i remember going down there to south
georgia going to their house
and of course they like just had this
like you know like just woods and fields
and stuff behind their house
and
of course
no helmet
no shoes
i just had on a pair of shorts and i'm
like
six
no instructions living free man they
just put you on the thing and then
they're just like this is how you go
they didn't even tell me how to stop you
know and and my parents are just like
inside just drinking cokes with
you know with my aunt and uncle like it
was just such a different time
and then my other cousins they had a
four-wheeler that's safer
doesn't roll as easily you can do two
wheels on the front too same deal though
no helmets
gotta i mean boy got away with so much a
lot of people weren't so lucky yeah
those those are accidents waiting to
happen
let's let's let's pick one more
to wrap it up
hi retinlink my name is mj at the
beginning of 2021 i did something really
stupid and nearly died when i had an
accidental drug overdose
i stopped breathing i couldn't move but
my thoughts were still really clear oh
gosh and in my mind i saw my mom's face
and i thought about how terrible this
was going to be for her
i saw my dog and i thought about how
much i loved her
and the last thing i saw was rhett and
link
sitting behind the desk
i'd been watching lots of gmm at the
time and it made sense
but i had this moment in my mind where i
just laughed at the absurdity that
my last thought in this life was going
to be about two guys who do goofy things
on the internet smiling gently at me
and it made me feel better as everything
went black
but i didn't die i got to live and the
next day when i was trying to decide
what it all meant i thought
well i am going to need a therapist a
program and a third degree membership in
the mythical society
and uh you comforted me when i thought i
was dying and it seemed the least i
could do
so that's what i did and it's going
really well
and it feels good to be able to tell you
and to thank you for your contribution
to my life
and millions of others
so thank you
and uh love you like a friend fellas
take care
i am so glad you're alive
wow uh i'm so glad that we could be
there for that moment i don't i don't
remember it like i've established i
don't know how this all works
i'm open to the fact that we um
may have somehow like been transferred
to your brain for a moment and just
smiled at you peacefully i don't know
how it works but
glad you're okay i mean i'm honored
i'm honored to be the last i mean we
could have been the last thing that
somebody thought of but she thought it
was she she got a laugh out got a laugh
out of going and going out with a laugh
that's good
and then coming back with a third degree
mythical society membership i mean what
a great average can we can we just use
that as a commercial
you know yeah we say
we save lives we have we appear to dying
people bring them back
so that they can join the mythical
society
that is wild man i mean and don't you
feel honored i feel i feel so it's like
her life is flashing before her eyes
we got in there with the mom and the dog
the final slide of her life flash
is us
oh man
man that's wild that is wild so you i
mean it feels like you got a little bit
shaken up
on this episode
i mean it's just
i'll never watch that netflix series
that's just not my type of thing and i'm
not gonna ever find myself reading
accounts of people waking up during
surgery i'm sorry but those feel like
different things though right because if
i told you
the near-death experience of course
they're waking up during surgery is just
like a horrific thing i get it
but the near-death experience there's a
fascinating aspect to it for me it's
just like i've just i've lived a life of
just
dismissing
and i still mostly dismiss all of it
right i'm like of course
you've got this perception this
perception network
you know all your senses and everything
you've got your brain of course
i would be surprised if there were not
stories like this as people approach
death as the system is shutting down
of course you're going to see some weird
stuff
um but if i could tell you that
like if i had one of these experiences
and i was telling it to you or
like i'm just fascinated because the you
know it is a netflix show it's just a
show i don't know these people it's
obviously produced it's obviously
curated in a way to from a certain
disposition the whole point of the
people behind this thing is to get you
to believe it you got to know that
there's
you know there's some propaganda
involved so you got to know when you're
being subjected to that
but like
don't you just want to know
aren't you just fascinated by it
i i get that it is the
the what happens afterward but like the
like that i'm
like when she's talking about like um
the nightmarish parts of like
being conscious but being unable to move
i know i'm not trying to go back to the
surgery part of it but like yeah it's
just like thinking of the ways that you
die that's it's um
i'm fascinated by the afterlife part of
it but the actual death is especially
the getting there is the problem yeah
but it's about the journey man
it's not the destination it's the
journey i mean am i going to appear to
myself smiling along with you well no
it'll probably just be me okay that must
be me sitting next to you i'll be in
your peripheral you'll have to turn
to see me right from your you'll be my
right as usual your seat at the desk
this is fine i mean the thing that i do
like i like hearing
people tell their stories it makes it
believable i mean of course i don't
believe anything anybody said today but
i almost do something cause i'm
listening to their voice 18888 earpod
one
i have a wreck
wreck it up it is a tick tock account oh
i'm always looking for more tick tocks
uh well i recently shared one of the
uh tick tocks from this particular
account with a group thread that we're
on oh you you're talking about the guy
talking about with beard vcr oh
underscore party
yeah yeah yeah
vcr underscore i found my love language
and it is watching
old footage
it turns out that this is the okay i
mean not a lot of followers
you know it's i mean it's not even a
verified account but it says official
tick tock of found footage festival
yeah yeah found footage festival been
going for many years i knew about that
so i mean i guess it is the official way
i need to get verified come on now
so i don't know how the rights to this
stuff work
but uh
i mean the thing that is the most
entertaining to me thus far and i
haven't dug deep the thing that i sent
the group is that dudes like there's
these dating profiles where people from
the 80s would go on and they would like
talk about themselves and apparently it
would like go out on a video tape for
women in the area to watch and figure
out if they want to date these guys and
there's just this one guy and he is just
the is the best it's like they don't
make people like that anymore like you
know what i'm saying i was like looking
not just this hair and the way he was
dressed but like the way he talked and
the way he moved his face and stuff yeah
um
i mean he had a marionette quality to
him just go just go to the account and
just start watching it's either you're
either going to love it or hate it you
know what i'm saying like either this is
what you like or this is like why does
anyone like this it's a lot better than
reading about all the other stuff that's
been reading about find out what kind of
person you are vcr underscore party on
tick tock love it
all right
how did that give me
i think i just choked for a second a
little hot sauce i choked on my thoughts
for me the lyrics to the song
sledgehammer went totally over my head i
uh
i watched that video a million times
because it was like a fun music video
and i was a little kid i don't know six
years old seven years old when it came
out i watched it constantly but like
open up your fruit cage and let me in
like
wow i had no idea hi my name's rachel
i'm a big fan um
so song lyrics that went over my head as
a kid
my parents were musicians so we always
had music playing in the house and i
remember a couple of specific songs um
the song hair of the dog by nazareth
features a lyric now you're messing with
a son of a blank
and when i was apparently a small child
and my sister too
my sister and i would run around singing
it in our squeaky little voices and dad
loved to tell that story um another time
we were listening to um
gosh i forget the name of the song but
it's by steely band
and the lyric is the cuervo gold the
fine colombian makes
i can't remember but um
i asked my dad what colombian meant
and it was a reference to drugs um
but he told me it's coffee baby
and he loved to tell that story too
um anyway i'm a big fan of you guys
thank you so much for doing what you do
bye hey rhett and link my girlfriend
sulcata desert tortoise and i are
canning out in the grass and we just
wanted to say
1888
earpods
[Music]
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]